And I'll flip the screen over in a
second. Let me set category.
Okay.
Um
I think we're good to start. So,
let me explain what is going on at the
moment, yes?
I came up with a cool project idea for
off policy correction.
I sort of pulled at that thread a bit. I
found a major issue with core PPO.
Um pretty large discovery with the way
it plays with moment and time.
It's even worse with Muon.
I threw a bunch of stupid codex at it.
Codex is really dumb.
Uh I figured out enough to figure out
like exactly more precisely the steps I
need to take to know what's going wrong.
I'm doing this in a much tighter loop
with Grok now
cuz it's faster.
And uh this is mostly me steering. So,
let's figure this out.
Let me remember where I was with this,
as well.
Right. So, we were basically trying to
figure out
uh the loss was destabilizing very
quickly.
And we were trying to figure out the
relative causes of that.
So, it was looking at scaling value and
policy loss separately.
Okay. So, the clip frac does jump based
on the policy grad coefficient.
So, I think movement was mostly just
being driven through the value head.
Let me think about this.
So,
we were doing this based on policy clip.
Oh, I'm just not taking into account the
value clip at all, am I?
Okay.
Let me think what the correct way to do
this is then.
Accumulation of momentum is fine.
The application and decay of momentum,
right?
That's actually very weird, isn't it?
With two heads like that.
Yeah, that's very weird.
Um
Well, why Wait wait a second. Why is it
weird?
It's just weird cuz we're summing
gradients, right?
Possibly we can compute that
efficiently.
For now, we just need to sort it out
though.
Entropy is already disabled, so we can
ignore that.
We are doing some core algorithm work
right now.
I just started.
Steps for us doesn't how many steps is
good or bad? I feel like
a lot of my experiments only start
going results after two. I mean, you
shouldn't have to think about that
because you should just be able to run
protein.
Like
the classic experiment thing with RL,
okay, is that your ends are really slow
and experiments are really long. So you
end up having to have this mental model
of like what's the probability this
experiment is worth continuing, yada
yada, and it's it's really annoying and
it takes up a lot of your mental
bandwidth.
Um
the cool thing with puffer is if your
experiments are just fast,
those 200 mil steps take a minute or
less.
Right?
Like 200 million steps, you know, we run
we have run experiments for a trillion
steps before.
That's the thing we can do on one
machine as well.
You'll notice that I'm doing this work
here on breakout.
Not all work can be done on breakout cuz
breakout is a very simple task, but
because this is specifically looking at
like um dynamics,
I have this task that I can train in
under 2 seconds,
or I can really crank up this low
ablation,
and it's still under a minute.
Couldn't get your
Huh? What type of model do you need?
We solve some pretty hard problems
with uh like our min grew arch is really
good. It's possible you need a custom
encoder for some tasks,
but those can be made very fast.
And um
not let it make any decisions about
things.
Yeah, I need to make sure I'm keeping
full track of everything.
a transformer on my resnet?
That seems pretty nuts.
Yeah, I just don't believe that you need
that heavy of a network, frankly.
It might be annoying. Uh we've seen
problems where it's annoying to get
anything without a couple cons.
But yeah, I don't believe that you just
can't learn anything without having a
giant resnet.
I believe that the defaults are super
tuned to this bloated resnet, sure.
>> NetHack has
no
overlapping cons.
I definitely need to look at your
architecture for that Finn. Also,
awesome result.
Like awesome awesome work on that
result.
Um
Yeah, man. I I honestly think that it's
just you were kind of getting memed on
by the score approach. Like
if everybody decides to optimize a
stupid metric and you're a PhD student,
you kind of just have to optimize the
stupid metric.
But, um
if you're not a PhD student, you can
just tell people that that's a dumb
metric and pick the one that makes
sense.
>> So, what we're doing here,
uh we now have a clip frac based clip
correction
that is calculated separately based on
policy and gradient clipping
applied to a very simplified optimizer,
which I think is just SGD with Nesterov
momentum.
Um
and the goal is to understand precisely
how the current
clipping fails to stabilize
updates
if you keep applying them.
I'm free to do a couple hours stream,
maybe.
And then I got to get ready for uh I
have business stuff to take care of
tomorrow.
Papers or academic research.
And make it the direction they're going.
Um
Have there been things last five
probably yes.
I'm trying to think like specifically
what we use.
Like there's research I've used that
isn't specifically RL that works for RL.
Are there any ends we use?
Um some of Michael's stuff, right? I
don't like the Jack's everything.
Like the work itself is good. It's sort
of held back by Jack's being a shitty
pain in the ass to work with and also
not fast.
Um
Well, I'd say like a lot of flare stuff.
We have uh actually there's some stuff
with NYU that we've been
It's not fully independent, but I I
really can't take much credit for it all
other than just we made their end fast.
Um there's some algorithm stuff from
them that's pretty good.
Overall, I'm definitely most excited
about the stuff that we're doing.
And I don't really see any other viable
path forward.
China actually has a a fair bit of
reasonable RL stuff.
Especially like game RL stuff. There's
actually quite a bit of it.
Conditional action trees.
Yeah, I don't remember how exactly how
old some of this stuff is Arch. Like
Chris Bamford stuff back when he did RL
was good. Obviously Costas stuff is
really good. Actually, I think Clean
Buzz within the last 5 years, which is
the async architecture that we're now
trying out for Puffer 5. Again, it's
Jax, but like the actual algorithm is
very nice.
Oak is like not a well-defined thing.
Um
It like I I don't know what he's doing
there.
Pretty much, yeah. The clipping thing.
Um
This is spinning for too long, but
I I'm doing like pretty precisely scoped
stuff with this.
I'm trying not to get too distracted.
Um
I need to understand the mechanism by
which we diverge with high sample reuse.
Right?
And if we Hang on, it's possible that
the the default clip frac is too
generous as well.
It should work with a tightened clip
frac, though, if this trust region makes
any sense.
So obvious. Is it, though? Like
I don't know. I heard Sutton speak in
person last year at RLC.
And it seemed like this really vague
hand-wavy thing.
Like
There's a lot of stuff that's like it
just for instance it assumed also oh
yeah, you just need some model-based
thing to fit in here somewhere. But like
model-based stuff doesn't work.
It's presented as if it does in the
literature, but like it doesn't actually
work. It's just really shitty and slow.
I think there's also this very heavy
emphasis on sample efficiency that I
think is just
fairly likely to be a pipe dream.
>> The hell?
I'll look into that, but thanks for the
report.
Why are you not using chat GPT?
Because if I were if I were on Codex
here, like I wouldn't be streaming. I'd
type this message and then I'd go leave
to do something else with my life for
the next 3 hours, and then I would come
back and it would be wrong anyways.
I know because that's exactly what I did
over the weekend.
Um
This is actually pretty bad how long
this is taking as is.
I don't know what it's doing. Where is
the
Waiting for long ablation sweep.
The hell?
Copper 5 is not released, but it is the
current dev branch.
I'm doing a little algo project on it.
Sample efficiency giving humans learned.
Humans are not tabular rasa.
Like humans don't learn from scratch at
all.
Not remotely.
These LMs do seem very smart. No, they
don't.
Not generally at least. They do
constantly utterly stupid stuff all the
time.
>> You need composable learning.
Learning from random weights for every
new situation is bad. Yeah, but what if
I can just train at like hundreds
of millions of steps per second? And I
can simulate everything super well.
Then why do I care?
Like, okay, you're going to train a
model on breakout and then it's going to
like
go
create some materials in a molecular
sim. No, there's no reusable information
there whatsoever.
Protein sweeps.
Those runs finished. Uh, let me take a
second uh look in a sec. Let's see. Let
me finish this thought here.
Five epochs.
Mu on made the biggest difference. Prior
sampling matters at short horizon
segment.
Uh, the biggest thing though is if
you're just running standard old Mujoco
is you're just your training is too
slow.
You're running at meme speeds. RL
doesn't work at meme speeds.
Our architecture makes a big difference
as well.
I'm Puffer would at least take your 50k
up to 400k on eight GPUs then, right?
L40s are also just terrible GPUs.
So, maybe you can get 800k plus on 8X
5090.
But, like you can't have a super slow
env and then expect stuff to run on like
a potato, right?
>> [snorts]
>> We actually Puffer uniquely does have RL
that works on a potato, but the env
can't be slow, right?
>> E P A to C. No, dude.
That's like
That's troll.
Am I thinking of a different GPU or
aren't those the super old ones?
Am I thinking of A40? No, am I thinking
of like something else?
Simple policy optimization.
If that's the paper I'm thinking of, I
don't think it works, but I I'll check
it after. As I'm not going to get super
derailed today because like I'm holding
a lot of information in my head right
now for this research. And if I'm if I
forget anything, I'm going to screw it
up.
Um this is actually like I know this is
still stupid grokking a loop, but like
these are actually very narrowly scoped
changes. And
if I can just go through this correctly,
you'll see that this is actually
probably a very big deal. Um here's what
I'm going to do.
Let me just Let me reiterate what I'm
doing. Uh, and then it'll sort of be
obvious why that this is so potentially
important, okay? We found a bad
interaction between
your standard optimizers and PPO that
essentially breaks the clipping
mechanism at high sample reuse. Such
that very high sample reuse breaks your
policy and it doesn't just get clipped.
So, increasing like more samples equals
policy catastrophically fails. This
shifts your entire space of hyper
parameters and clip coefficients and
just makes everything feel very unstable
and janky.
It's I'm thinking that we can actually
fix this at an algorithmic layer at the
algorithmic level by introducing
clipping terms into the momentum of the
optimizer. If we can get this to work,
it will mean that you can crank up
sample reuse any amount that you want
and your training will remain stable.
This would in turn make the entire range
of clip hyper parameters much much more
consistent and predictable. And instead
of having experiments like fail if your
parameters are slightly off, they would
just like take slightly longer or you
know be slightly suboptimal in terms of
samples or wall clock. You would not get
the same hard failure behavior. So,
that's what we're going for right now.
>> See, it can't even run the experiments
correctly as described. You have to be
very careful.
Just the best way I can describe this is
that like everything will just feel less
janky in general. I think it's going to
be more stable configs, but that's not
it. Like the space of configs is just
going to be better behaved.
>> EPO ratio getting closer.
Higher sample reuse should push the
ratio farther away from one.
Um, but what we're seeing is
it's a bit different.
Sample reuse is less one off policy is
bad. It is.
But like
even off though off policy is bad, like
it's not a difference in that, it's a
difference in how you handle the
degradation. Right?
You do not handle degradation. Stay on
policy.
Yeah, but like, okay. So,
the issue with this, right, is you're
off policy after literally the first
mini batch.
Okay?
And then some M's are going to be slower
or faster than others.
So, with async training, you're actually
with a new async mode, you are
incentivized to keep spinning the GPU
for as long as it takes you to get new
data, even if it's very fast, because
the training is also very fast.
Um
but the issue, right, is that like
even at like RR2 or something, you also
can you can already be incurring
significant off policy drift.
And
the mechanism by which that gets
incorporated is very janky and it's
fundamentally broken for PPO.
It has to do with the momentum term of
the optimizer.
Dude, A2C does not work. I don't know
what to tell you. Like, go ahead, go try
that. Replace buffers PPO with A2C, go
resweep, it won't work.
Like, I've run experiments like this
before.
Even with very low sample reuse, you
still need the clipping factor. Stuff
blows up.
You're less reliant on the clipping
factor than you are in like a 4x sample
reuse setting, but you're still reliant
on it.
Like, you have to keep in mind that
almost every possible question you ask,
like I actually have run tons of
experiments on because our ex- like, our
setup is so fast, right?
Like, that among many other versions
I've tested.
LR scheduler.
Uh LR scheduler alone does not fix it.
It's It's not the learning rate.
Learning rate is actually
already fine.
Even the accumulation of momentum looks
fine.
It's kind of like
there's something pretty similar to an
exponentially decaying average on
momentum within each epoch that's bad.
And then the There's also a separate
application step that is bad as well.
It's not quite LR schedule. It's a bit
different.
Momentum schedule, I guess, but it's not
a scheduler in the sense that it
shouldn't be just based on the iteration
index.
Uh I believe TRPO has the same problem,
Jess.
Like this is not an issue
with the calculation of the region. It's
an It is a bad interaction with the
optimizer.
Yeah, reinforce also like Giga does not
work.
Like the thing that actually makes RL
work,
it's the clip term and then generalized
advantage estimation.
Like those are the things that make RL
work. It does not work without them.
I could be wrong on TRPO, Jess. I'd have
to recheck, but I'm pretty damn sure.
Like PPO is just like oh, TRPO, but
actually we can make it way simpler and
it does the same thing.
>> Now, I've been thinking about this a lot
though. I literally had a dream last
night that I just happened to walk by
Schulman and I asked him about this and
he's like, "Oh, yeah. That seems like
you probably needs to be fixed."
natural gradient optimizer. In that case
then it's fine, but um
it doesn't
like PPO just used Adam.
And there's clearly an issue there.
The first mini batch again, you don't
like use PPO but only the first mini
batch. Like
Bister, you need to go reread the paper.
The first mini batch of PPO, the entire
clipping term cancels to one.
Unless you're doing async training.
I chat I only chatted with him a few
times at OpenAI.
Um
he seemed chill. He was definitely way
more on algo side where I was spending a
lot more time thinking about
environments and engine to support all
the stuff.
>> Flight A2C you didn't notice.
Of course I noticed, dude.
I built pufferlab.
>> I still think that's not Does A2C
original have JAE in it? I didn't think
it did.
You still do get JAE. The JAE term
doesn't cancel.
He likes physics. No, I don't know.
Maybe, probably.
I have no idea what the hell Rock is
doing here.
I'm telling you you still need the um
the clip coefficient. Even if you do one
epoch over the data, you're literally
doing like batch gradient descent
otherwise.
So, I don't know what the hell's up with
that. To be fair, like the guy was nice
and has done some reasonable work
before, but I just don't believe that
that thing makes any damn sense.
Like okay, I'll agree that the like A2C
is very clean in the sense of if you
want to do something simple like and do
it well, that might be better than doing
something more complex and doing it
incorrectly.
But you really really weaken the
algorithm.
Uh wait, hang on. I missed some
messages. Do you shuffle mini batches?
Uh it's actually it's sampled
probabilistically already.
So, we don't like
we go over it based on
advantage or whatnot. And if you set
that to zero, the result would just be
random sampling. So, yes.
Stupid bots.
Um
we are currently working on
we're ablating the effects of off-policy
drift on PPO and we're trying to come up
with a specific optimizer fix.
But at the time being, I'm mostly just
trying to understand
exactly how and where
the current thing fails.
Yeah. I'm going to use the restroom real
quick. I'll be right back.
Is there a chance to get the same
sample? Yes.
It's sampling um
It's sampling with replacement. I don't
think that's a problem.
Uh I don't think these models are good
enough for that. I think it's
I think that there's still significant
advantage to me just being very precise
about what I
what what I say.
And
uh I can do that much more effectively
by typing.
Eventually longer term, probably yes.
>> Yeah, the models can barely follow
instructions correctly even for narrowly
scoped tasks when they are well
described.
Um, I I'm for something like this, I
would not want to try this.
Like I think that it would literally be
faster for me to try do everything fully
manually than to try to get it with this
if I were going to do it that way.
It's kind of funny the discrepancy. Like
we're at the point in my mind where the
models are still incredibly stupid in a
number of very like bad ways.
They're definitely useful, but they're
incredibly stupid.
Tough work.
I guess they're kind of just building
assuming the models will get better.
Google's always been cooked though.
They win by virtue of being really big
and having some good people there
because they're really big.
>> I wonder if we can solve if we can solve
without momentum entirely.
I think that's the next thing. This this
approach is a very annoying one. It This
is a very thorough thing where we kind
of just like break the problem down to
the simplest case and then try to build
it back up.
Sometimes it works. Sometimes it ends up
being difficult.
Did it work? I don't see what you did.
Not done yet, Ethan. Still lots of
experiments to run.
So like
the path here
all right
like this is the path if I can like sort
of show this right so like
EPO clips
why does high sample reuse
lots of all
instead of getting clipped
add a bunch of cracking
momentum both don't
with
size and increasing
policy nest
nest
remove
log
test
dip rack
and
realize you eat
now
all clip
play
all still
mixed
trying to remove momentum
rank down flip racks
up RR
We are here. There.
That's it.
What projects would you suggest doing to
learn RL? We have an article on that.
If you check on my X account,
um there is like a ultra opinionated
guide to RL and it kind of just walks
you through the process of learning and
what projects we'd recommend like the
type of projects we'd recommend
and uh lots of people have done this and
learned quite a bit of RL and have
become productive contributors as well
even to puffer.
Use dictation? No.
2:31 a.m. right now.
2:31 a.m. is pretty good.
I actually I don't know how the
curriculum has changed. I think I linked
earlier versions of the course.
So, I don't know if it's better or worse
now than it used to be.
Oh, yeah. Also, star the puffer on
GitHub. That helps us a lot. It's free.
3 to 4 hours reading per weekday.
Um
I mean, you mostly have to do a lot of
research. Like, 20% of your time still
needs to be on formal learning. You read
some papers, right? You go through some
obvious background material.
Um but most of it needs to just be doing
actual research. Like, the reality of it
is most PhDs, like before you start your
PhD,
most people have already done a couple
years of full-time research.
At least most good ones.
I basically spent half of my time
throughout my entire undergrad just
doing research.
Like, so
there you go, right?
Definitely you can get pretty good, um,
like quicker than that
with some good mentorship and you know,
if you're smart.
But it is tough.
I sort of explained a lot of like how I
think about research to Spencer earlier
today. It's
it's a lot, honestly.
It's like a very peculiar It's a
peculiar skill set.
You kind of need to like be hanging on
to a lot of different threads
and knowing when they conflict and how
you weight them.
>> I'm actually not organized at all is the
funny thing in many ways.
Like
if anything the only thing that is
organized like the only thing organized
is my thoughts
in my life. [laughter]
My thoughts are very organized.
This one fails.
It seems.
This is super annoying. Let's just
Give me my full line.
Okay, this was supposed to be 64.
Not 164.
There's not a way to measure drift
between two policies that isn't just on
the current samples, right?
Like I guess the overall thing would be
KL.
It doesn't. Okay, so you can't
compensate fully.
>> The fraction is pretty low.
Oh, but it's going to vary over the
batch.
We have to be very precise here, don't
we?
Very precise.
>> That's what I'm thinking, but like just
how, right? So
KL on what?
Three minutes fine. Yeah, that'll do it.
So, what if we just let's think let's
just completely discard
clip coeff, right?
Cuz like
very clearly clip coeff alone does not
give us a stable range for updates. It's
not effective as a trust region at all.
Speaking of like what do we get for
TRPL? Let's Let's go look at Do I really
want to go look at TRPL math?
Jesus Christ, do I really want to look
at this thing?
Okay, what if I skip the derivation
here?
I always ignored this paper because PPO
just worked.
And now I get bitten for it.
Wait, what?
Is this a weight space constraint?
No, I I I just I need the I need to go
through the the counters to make sure
I'm not missing anything, Jess. It
doesn't mean we're returning to
TRPO. I just need to make sure I'm not
missing anything and being stupid.
>> Yeah, I know that this is a common
technique.
>> Man, I never bothered with this thing
because the empirical results were about
the same.
It's I saw conjugate gradient like once
in my undergrad
Yeah, we'll just call it we'll keep it
PPO, but it stands for proper policy
optimization.
Or what can I do reward?
Uh
I think we had
the stable version is whatever Finn just
PR'd in the last like
month and a half.
He fixed a bunch of stuff. I If you're
just seeing stuff crash, you're probably
on a version that still has like bugs on
continuous action spaces.
>> using Finn system. It's my own Sam and
basically
how can I not care about time to get the
not care as much about So, time to get
the reward is implicit.
Um the extent to which the agent wants
to get the reward quickly is embedded in
the gamma term of generalized advantage
estimation.
So, provided you do have the continuous
fixes,
that's basically it. We've done several
control problems.
Hopper should be able to smash those. I
will say though, like Finn did a lot of
work on tuning the drone sim to be
really good.
Like, have you seen the latest version
of this thing?
Like, look at this. This is just
ridiculous.
All right, look.
Drone racing, okay, but then the same
policy,
sphere formation, same policy,
cube,
same policy,
America,
hover at location,
back to racing,
same policy.
>> How long does policy training take for
drone? I don't know, ask him. I think
it's quick.
400 mil.
So, depending on how fast this is,
probably a few minutes.
Maybe less.
Are you emotionally in good shape right
now?
Yeah, that like I that's those aren't
like things I consider, my guy.
>> [laughter]
>> It's like if work is going well, I'm
normally just doing well. If work is not
going well, I'm normally annoyed.
Well, it's saying I have a whole bunch
of things in my head that I'm trying to
figure out what's going on here.
Rock.
Honestly,
I'm really happy with this model.
This is the only thing that does not
make my job absolutely miserable.
Like
Well, I mean compared to the other
models, right? It's not miserable with
no model. It's actually pretty chill.
Uh, it's just I would be doing slightly
different work.
The reason is it's fast. Like that's
literally just the reason.
If model has to spin for an hour every
single time I do something minor, it's
worthless.
5.6 all awful model.
Awful awful model.
Spins for 3 hours, reward hacks your
thing with some obvious dumb It's just
not smart. Like none of the models are
smart. So if the model's not going to be
smart, I want it to at least fail
quickly so I can fix it.
Ooh, okay.
8 seconds, right?
Here is where we need the momentum
correction.
Kimmy, I've not tried Kimmy.
Uh we could try Deep Seek I could
potentially try.
Does anybody have one of the charts that
shows like the uh
model cuz I definitely I I definitely
wouldn't want to get something that's
significantly dumber than this model.
To make it faster.
I think like the quality of this model
but faster is
about like I've tried like the really
fast models and they're cool
but they're just really really dumb.
Like at the point where you lose the
ability to follow basic instructions
after a step or two, it's just no longer
useful.
Give me slow, then it's not worth it
then.
59 token. Are these token per second
serving numbers accurate?
No, dude. These are not accurate.
There's no way because this thing is
literally like 10x slower. So, I don't
trust these numbers.
Yeah, I don't trust these numbers at
all.
I don't understand then why people
haven't figured it out the right metric
to report then. They should simply
report if they're going to report their
score on the task, then they should
report their score on the task, right?
And then the time in seconds it took to
solve that like if the time in seconds
the benchmark took.
>> I don't know. It's
It's very obvious if you like use these
and are not an idiot. Like, okay, maybe
the models are very smart in some narrow
ways, but like they're also incredibly
stupid in some pretty broad ways.
Okay, so
interesting.
Meta's model
is 150.
I mean, how long is it
if it solves stuff fast, EA?
I need a quick break. I'm going to rest
and grab a drink.
And we'll continue.
Hello, puffer.
>> All right.
I I understand a little bit.
I understand a little bit.
I think.
So, the problem is you can't just set a
KL target.
Because
the meaning of that changes over
training.
That actually kills TRPL as well,
doesn't it?
>> Mhm.
That's bad.
I see. So, you already have
Okay, so the KL target is actually
reasonable.
This is me just being dumb.
I'll admit that.
Cuz it's logs Okay, yeah, that's
actually fine then. Chaos is what you
want.
So,
Find that KL early stopping. This
doesn't seem to work either.
I just checked that I thought the KL is
supposed to be adaptive.
Oh, this can also still be momentum,
right?
Did you have a way of doing that that
was like principled or were you just
annealing it over training?
>> Neural MMO
You can go play it online.
Watch our agents play it. It's a
massively multi-agent game.
You only have it deployed with like four
agents, but if you play the local
version, there'll be a thousand.
If I just open this thing up
and I just tap control once,
now I can play it.
Why is it all super laggy? That's awful.
I got to fix the perf on this.
This did not used to be like this, so
something changed.
Not that bad.
But yeah, you can like fight enemies.
This guy has a bow, you probably don't
want to get in line with him.
You can hit space to attack.
You don't have a bow a weapon yet, so
you need to get a weapon. Typically, you
kill This guy's going to shoot me.
I typically you get a weapon by killing
a low-level enemy. They'll drop a tool,
use the tool to harvest some resources.
Like this level one I'd want to kill
here, but I can't get to him because the
other guys will kill me in the way.
And you can actually, if you just hit
control again, the agent will take over
and will attempt to play. So, I don't
think there's much way to win with uh
the way I've set it up here.
Did you program this? Yeah.
This was before uh language models could
do anything.
It took me, I don't know, 2 3 months of
work.
Um it's all open source. It's one big
file. It's like 3K lines or something.
Uh good chunk of it is the rendering.
It runs pretty fast. You can get this
thing up to like a million steps a
second, 1.5 million steps a second per
CPU core.
It's pretty good.
No, this was actually a follow-up to my
PhD thesis.
I did this right after I graduated,
like, okay, what if I just redid my PhD
project, but I made it better by doing
actual good engineering this time
with all the stuff I know now.
I worked really hard learning this stuff
when I was younger, man.
I had like
you know, at least
80 to 90 hours worth of other stuff to
do per week and I still put in like 20
hours a week learning this stuff
um before my internship.
And then
I actually I found the research I've
always found harder to put in the really
good hours on, but I still put in like
70.
Same way as everybody trains. You just
you read papers, you try to do stuff.
The re-approaches for adaptive KL. Okay.
Thank you.
Wait. I think this works, doesn't it?
we're good, right?
Yeah, okay.
Dang, this is not stable either. That's
crazy.
Not able to understand. I have guides.
I published lots of educational content
on X.
I'm trying to think what the best metric
is.
Like, do you see what I'm trying to do
here? I'm trying to figure out like, how
do we know
when we're messing up the policy too
much? I think it's got to be important
sampling, right?
Possibly this gives us something too
conservative.
>> Mhm.
That's not potato potato, is it?
You check how policy drifts over the
entire segment.
Expected expectation of the log of
important sampling.
Uh, hang on. I think you're right. Is
this
So, I guess we'll see if we can can this
up or not.
So, actually, hang on. This is where
conflating this with the uh the momentum
update, aren't we?
We are conflating this with momentum
update.
This is why this type of work I
shouldn't do for too many hours.
I start making bad mistakes.
So, let me think about this. We have
a few different methods for determining
how far policy shifts.
We already have that A-10. We are like
that exact thing, like read the proper
blog.
Yeah, I like this.
Good specialized robot.
>> It's a conflict, but it's not huge
though, is it?
No one is interested in mentoring
anybody.
We've literally trained dozens of people
in RL. It's just jump in
discord.gg/potfor
news all the materials.
Like Spencer came in without RL
experience. He's crushing professional
projects.
We've got lots of people that are doing
like really impressive RL work.
Ben to my knowledge didn't have any RL
experience.
He is like interning with us this summer
and he is just completely sodaing
everything.
I mean, that doesn't mean it's easy,
right? It takes a lot of work and stuff,
but it is doable.
You got some good stuff, convert. At
least the stuff that you
you don't just fully let codex do
or whatever.
I think I might just be really stupid,
huh?
It drives close to PR worthy.
I will hold you to that, Kinvert.
All right, here's the promise, right?
The next time I do a batch of end
reviews,
you tell me which one you want me to
review first.
Um
if I can just by like looking at it for
a few minutes and having Grok run like a
few passes of Joseph's stupid refactor
algorithm, if I can cut off like more
than a third of the code, the code was
bad.
I think that's going to be the uh
that's going to be the standard.
>> [laughter]
>> And I'm going to have fun doing that on
a bunch of PRs.
Maybe 10%? I will hold you to that.
If I can only cut off 10% of your code,
it's generally pretty good.
No, no, no, the tests don't count. We
only count source in the PRs.
So, don't worry about that. I'm not
going to be like I'm not going to just
be a dick for the sake of being a dick.
I'm only going to be a dick if it's
productive to be a dick. All right?
Like as in you submit code that I cut
half off of and it still works the same.
One of the biggest things I want to work
on Puffer? Yeah.
More Puffer.
We definitely need people like we need
good people on Puffer.
Oh, I'll show you the skill file real
quick.
It's called skillissues.md. It's one
screen.
Here's your Here's your preview of it.
It's really dumb.
But I basically I just wrote down how I
refactor code.
Oops, let's not delete it.
This is basically how I refactor code.
I don't know if this is pushed.
It will be if it isn't.
Oh, but wait. If you're going to No, no,
no. If you're just going to run the
skill file for me, cut off like, you
know,
a third of the code and say like, "See,
it's good."
Then you're not going to learn things.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, man. You can
do that after I've at least like
reviewed one of your end and showed you
like most likely showed you that the
code was very bloated.
But you need to like appreciate
I think in order to learn people need to
at least see one time that they take
something that they think is really
compact and then I just cut half of it
off.
I mean, you guys can do it if you want,
but like the reason I tell you not to is
it's an educational thing, right? Like
if you want to learn from the thing,
then I would encourage you to figure out
of how how well you can tighten your
code.
It's really good to see like a
I think it's really good for people to
see a big disparity between the thing
that they think is compact and what's
actually compact.
Get results out of LLMs.
Not learning C.
the reason you can't get good results
out of LLM's
it's typically well one they're very
stupid but then like if they're very
stupid somebody has to be smart for the
result to be good.
How to max citations in RL? Sure, do the
shiniest thing possible regardless of
whether it works or not or makes any
sense. Um
a blade a thing into existence until you
get one incredibly brittle result and
then claim you've solved everything.
Rock control V.
The clipboard's a little dicey.
Follow a student in RL.
I mean I do I have entire educational
stuff for you, man.
Like, if you just go to my articles tab,
they're my two highest-rated articles.
Here's my advice for programming in ML.
Here's my advice for RL.
>> What? Within epoch
1 5
Is that consistent?
Okay, at least the value grad that
doesn't make sense, right?
At least the value grad doesn't make
sense.
Value grad has
>> I'll be right back. Let me use the
restroom and uh we will continue a
little bit.
Just a little bit more though.
Oh, and uh actually let me just check
one thing. No messages, good. Be right
back.
All clueless.
Hang on, I'll I'll explain.
Huh.
I'll then copy a lot of similar style.
I mean they're trained on that garbage,
right?
Not that surprising.
we've gone through lots of different
clip versions, lots of different
momentum things.
>> I don't know. It's probably like just
trained on a lot of big tech
This is wild.
DRPO, yeah, they're they're two
different things that link together.
Hang on, let me check.
One let me check one thing here.
Dinner in 15.
Um so let me let's just like make sure I
actually finish this.
>> rashes.
Interesting.
What is the correction that we would
want here?
>> I'm trying to think what the correction
would be.
Number of time samples used? No, that's
not it.
That Twitch must have done that.
It's probably placeholder.
Yeah I could I can upload those at some
point. Um
Like short self-play M's or like
decently short self-play M's with good
per for useful.
Yeah.
I definitely need to do more strength
work.
Been a little lazy this summer, but I am
super lean.
Lights out on to job application for a
startup. That's cool.
>> All right, figured out the CUDA mini
batch thing, yay.
Think I'm doing makes sense. I think it
does.
It's a pure momentum change, isn't it?
Oh, that's why Mu Lan would hide it,
wouldn't it?
I'm gaining some insight on this problem
at the very least.
I I do think I'm going to call it in a
second here.
I'm schedule looking like I have a big
meeting tomorrow.
And then we'll see how I'm feeling after
that.
I'm trying to think how this should be
scaled.
>> I think this is just the type of thing
where I'm going to have to do some quiet
work off stream. Like going through Mu
on, going through a couple different
optimizer formulations.
All right, I'm going to call it for
today.
Uh thank you folks. Thank you for tuning
in.
If you are new around here, please start
the puffer on GitHub. It really does
help me out a lot and it is free.
A few people watching still.
On Twitch as well. That's nice.
Um
This is expected to be kind of tricky,
otherwise somebody would have figured it
out by now, but I'm hoping this makes a